[Music]
look at that shirt
what i think
[Music]
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
floyd
let's go baby
[Applause]
[Music]
189.
189 baby
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
everybody back up back up everybody back
up everybody back
[Music]
all right up
[Applause]
[Music]
is
during the weigh-in but same here i
don't think we need it
it'll be good but it would have been
cool
weigh-ins where today it's the first
time this fight
actually felt legit and really big
really big fight man logan shredded
floyd shredded we got a fight on our
hands how long is he gonna go
it's up to floyd and i'm actually
excited for this now so you saw
everything
some with luke thomas brian campbell
matt barnes
cyborg it's all behind the scenes it's a
lot of work
but it's great it's not really worked so
that's it man i hope you guys enjoyed it